MARY TURNER:
There's a great deal
of prejudice in
the United Kingdom
towards Irish Travellers.
You hear stories all
the time about how dirty
they are, how they leave
conditions in terrible places,
how unpleasant they are.
And they were nothing like that.
None of those
stereotypes ever fitted.
NARRATOR: Irish travelers are
a nomadic ethnic group living
throughout Ireland and the UK.
They traditionally move in
caravans living in encampments
alongside roadways.
MARY TURNER: Many of the
Travellers are illiterate.
Through years of moving around,
many of them don't read.
They don't write.
NARRATOR: That's Mary
Turner, a photojournalist who
spent seven years getting to
know a group of Travellers who
face marginalization and
are stereotyped because
of their unique lifestyle.
MARY TURNER: They
were far from dirty.
They're the cleanest
people I've ever known.
You'll notice that
inside their trailers,
everything is covered in plastic
so that the children don't
make anything dirty.
NARRATOR: Laws introduced
in 1994 gave police
greater authority
to evict Travellers
from roadside encampments, which
led many Travellers to settle
at Dale Farm, near Essex,
hoping to form a community.
MARY TURNER: They
live tightly together,
away from the outside
world, and they totally
depend on each other.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARY TURNER: Their weddings,
Christmas celebrations,
Holy Communions-- these
celebrations will go on
for days.
At a wedding, there
are no invites.
It's just whoever wants to come.
They're really
amazing occasions,
but it's also one of
the most important days
in a Traveller girl's life.
NARRATOR: In 2011, after
a dispute over planning
permissions, the
families at Dale Farm
were evicted, resulting in the
displacement of 80 Traveller
families and 45 arrests.
After protesters became
involved, tensions escalated.
MARY TURNER: The eviction
was particularly brutal.
Riot police came pouring down
the hill behind the site,
started tearing down
walls, screaming, shouting,
and I remember my friends'
children standing there
in tears.
Just-- in their own
country, I think,
feeling something that I
never expected to witness.
NARRATOR: Since being
evicted from Dale Farm,
some Travellers
have wanted to find
more stability in their lives.
MARY TURNER: I think they
realize the importance now
of settling a little and
allowing their children to go
to school and engaging with the
world around them a little bit
more.
They have, over the last three
or four years, all got iPhones.
When I first went,
they were terrified
of the idea of photographs
being put on Facebook.
And now, they quite
regularly do that themselves.
And that's really
helping them to overcome
some of those challenges
that I've mentioned.
Engaging with technology is
hugely important for the future
of their community.
NARRATOR: Many families
have been forced back
on the road and risk
being stopped by police.
Last year, Mary
traveled with them
and witnessed the treatment
they face by skeptical and wary
British citizens.
MARY TURNER: I really
saw for the first time
then what that was like,
actually driving through town
and having people look at
you, having the police pull up
and speak to you.
People are always
afraid of things
that they don't understand.
That's why I felt it was so
important as a photographer
to try and show the things
that we have in common.
NARRATOR: Don't forget to
subscribe to Seeker Stories,
and click here to learn about
the human cost of jade mining
in Myanmar.